THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING ALL THE STAFF WOULD
MEAN A RETURN OF CAPITAL
POSSIBLE DURING ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN CONSIDERATIONS WERE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SO WE
CAN ONLY HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF FOLKS WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. ROSS
REQUIRED THE MASTERY WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WERE PARTICIPATING
IN ANY OF OUR SITES IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE TO YOU. IT'S THE
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE
HOUSE THAT MEMBERS BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED FOR HEARING WEARING A
MASK IS ALSO A REQUIREMENT OF
BEING PROPERLY ATTIRED. WE HAVE
THREE BILLS ARE GENDER EACH
BILL CAN HAVE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION. EACH MAIN WITNESS
GETS TWO MINUTES EACH. PLEASE
BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO COMMENT WHEN YOU CALL IN TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE
ASK THAT YOU ONLY STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
OF THE BILL. IF YOU SEE MORE
YOU WILL BE CUT OFF BY THE
OPERATOR WE WANNA GIVE
EVERYBODY EQUAL TIME. IF YOU'RE
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH THE
PHONES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR
THE PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THIS WILL BECOME PART
OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE
BILL. YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN
EMAIL TO COMMITTEE STAFF. WITH
A COUPLE DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE IF YOU MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. R. N. GIVEN THE
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN
A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
ALL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALASKA YOU NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. AND WE
ASK YOU TO EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE.
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. IN ADDITION TO THIS
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO HAVE.
WITNESSES WHO CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. OF THE MAIN
ROOM IS IN THE STATE CAPITOL
ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
TESTIMONY LIFE. IN ADDITION TO
THOSE TWO OPTIONS THE PUBLIC
CAN MAKE USE OF ONE OF OUR
REMOTE TEST- TESTIMONY
STATIONS. LOCATED ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL ALSO
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN. SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIFE. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY TO BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE PLAN DO SO IS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOUR TESTIMONIES
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED ON THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE BACKGROUND
NOISE INCLUDING MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND THE
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
YOU WILL REMAIN A LIFELINE AND
YOU TO MEET YOURSELF THAT
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY ISSUES YOU
CAN CALL OUR COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO EIGHT FIVE. PER SHARE WAS
PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING AT
THIS MOMENT. WE DO NOT YET HAVE
QUORUM SO WE ARE GOING TO
PROCEED AS A SUB COMMITTEE. ARE
AND WHEN WE DO GET QUORUM WE
WILL CALL FOR THAT AND SO WITH
THAT. WE'RE GOOD. IF THAT- WE
HAVE FIVE MISTER BENNETT HERE
FILE ITEM. ONE AB.
EIGHT SIX
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GERMAN.
I'D LIKE TO WEAR THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE HERE
TODAY A. B. C. H. SIXTY ONE
CLARIFIES ANY RULES RELATING TO
SUB LEASING OR RENTING A
MANUFACTURED MOBILE HOME PARK
APPLY EQUALLY TO MANAGEMENT AND
RESIDENTS. BUT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE ONE IMPORTANT
CONCEPT HERE THAT I THINK IS
HAS NOT BEEN ADEQUATELY
EXPRESSED BY MYSELF EVEN AS I
TRIED TO ADVOCATE FOR THIS AND
IT IS SIMPLY THIS THERE IS A
LIMITED SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THERE IS AN INCENTIVE FOR PARK
OWNERS TO BUY THESE MOBILE HOME
PARKS. I'M SORRY FOR THESE PARK
OWNERS TO BUY THESE MOBILE
HOMES AND THEY COME AVAILABLE.
AND ULTIMATELY THAT CAN
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF FORMAL
HOUSING OUT THERE BECAUSE THEY
WILL HAVE. THE POTENTIAL TO
AVOID THE- RESTRICTIONS ON
RANTS THAT APPLY TO- THE MOBILE
HOMES THAT ARE OWNED BY THEIR
CURRENT TENANTS. ARE THAT'S THE
REAL FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE HERE AND
THIS IS NOT AN ATTEMPT TO
CHANGE THE LAW. THIS IS OUR
CHANCE TEMP TO TRY TO CLARIFY.
OR IMPLEMENT THE LAW AS DEFINED
BY KAMALA HARRIS WHEN SHE
OFFERED HER OPINION AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN. IN MY DISTRICT THERE
ARE EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MANUFACTURED HOMES- AND THE
OPINION MAKES A DIFFERENCE TO
THEM AND MAKES A DIFFERENCE TO
ALL OTHER PEOPLE THAT MAY
ULTIMATELY BE WANTING OR
NEEDING. TO BUY- A MANUFACTURED
HOME. AND SO AB EIGHT SIXTY ONE
WILL PROTECT THOSE LOW INCOME.
RESIDENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE BRUCE
DOWN THE LEGAL COUNSEL FOR OUR
GSM- WELL ONLINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BEFORE WE PROCEED I'M GONNA
ASK US TO TAKE THE WORLD
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY. CHILL Q. HERE THEY
ARE TELL HI THERE. XARELTO HERE
GABRIEL. KALRA KALRA HERE KILEY
KILEY HERE MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SILVA QUIKSILVER HERE WICKS. WE
HAVE QUORUM WITHOUT SIR WHEN WE
PROCEED TO YOUR MAIN WITNESS-
TO THE OPERATOR WE HAVE BRUCE
STANTON FROM GUESS MALL ON THE
LINE IF YOU COULD PLEASE LET
HIM. SPEAK YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
THAT. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STANTON GENERAL COUNSEL FOR GSM
ALLOW IT SUPPORTS. LOCAL
RESIDENTS ARE UNEQUALLY TREATED
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ABILITY TO
RECTOR SO PLEASE THEIR HOMES
WELL MOST PARKS HAVE RULES
PROHIBITING RESIDENTS FROM
RENTING- SO PLEASE TAKE AT BATS
HIS MIND ACCORDING TO THE LAW.
DOES SAY PARKS OFTEN PURCHASE
AND WRAPPED UP- SO PLEASE
VOEPEL OFFICE OWNED BY PARK
MANAGEMENT. THIS RESULTED IN
THAT SITUATION WHERE THE PARK
OWNER IS NOT FOLLOWING ITS OWN
RULES. AND GET THE BENEFIT OF
SELF POLICING WHILE PARK
RESIDENTS DO NOT. THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
OPINION. OF COMELEC HARRIS
DECLARED THAT BASED ON THE
EXISTING VOEPEL PRESIDENCY LAW
PARK RULES APPLY EQUALLY TO
MANAGEMENT AND RESIDENTS. AT A
PARK OWNER IS ALSO ABOUT TO
FOLLOW ITS RULES PROHIBIT
EXCEPT LEASING. BARGAINERS
DISTINGUISH THE OPINION BY
SAYING WILL PROHIBITING
RESIDENTS FROM SUB LEASING
QUOTE UNQUOTE DOES NOT APPLY TO
THEM SINCE THEY OWN THE HOMES
AND ARE DIRECTLY WRENCHING THAT
QUOTE UNQUOTE. BUT THIS IS A
DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE WHETHER CALL
THE RATTLERS SUBLEASE THE END
RESULT IS THE SAP. IT RESIDENTS
CANNOT SUBLEASE TO READ PARK
MANAGEMENT SHOULD BE EQUALLY
BOUT IT SHOULD ABIDE BY ITS OWN
RULES. THE MRL SHOULD BE
ADMITTED TO SPECIFICALLY
ELIMINATE THIS DOUBLE STANDARD.
TO FINAL KEY POINTS FIRST THIS
BILL DOES NOT IMPEDE A PARK
OWNERS ABILITY TO CREATE OR
CHANGE PARK RULES IF A PARK
OWNER WISHES TO BAN SUBLEASE
AGO RANKING. THE KITCHEN USED
HAVE UNILATERAL ABILITY TO DO
SO OR IF YOU WISH TO ALLOW SO
POLICING CORRECTING IF I DO SO.
SECOND THE BILL DOES NOT
PREVENT A PARKING OF FROM
HOUSING EMPLOYEES AT THE PARK
BUT SIMPLY CLARIFIES ONCE A
PARK WATER MAKES THE DECISION.
TO ALLOW OR PROHIBIT SUBLEASE
YOU CORRECTING THAT EVERYONE
INCLUDING THE PARK AUTONOMOUS
FAIRLY A BITE. AND FOLLOW THOSE
SAME RULES. ON THAT BASIS
RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA GO
TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND WE'VE WON ONE IS
HERE AND THE COMMITTEE ROOM
MISTER GOVERNOR. IF YOU LIKE TO
WATCH- MAKE YOUR OPPOSITION
PRESENTATION AND WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER WITNESS BY PHONE MISTER
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- STAFF
AND THANK ACTUALLY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR GIVING
US PROBABLY MORE THAN ENOUGH
TIME SO THANK YOU. FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE FUNDAMENTAL
PREMISE IS WRONG BETWEEN
SUBLETTING RENTING THE PARK
OWNER DOESN'T SUBLET AND HAS A
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION. SOMEONE
WHO RENTS THE LAND FROM US THEN
RE RENTS A SOMEONE WHO WE DON'T
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH US IS
A SUB LETTER. APARTMENTS ARE
STATUTORILY FORBIDDEN FROM
SUBLETTING IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
OUR RESEARCH WE CAN'T FIND
OTHER STATES THAT ALLOW IT. NOR
THAT MANDATE THE MOBILE HOME
PARK ON IS AFTER ALLOW AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE FACT ON
RENT CONTROL IF YOU SIMPLY
ALLOW SUBLETTING EVERYWHERE IT
WILL BLOW UP AND MAKE RECONCILE
POINTLESS. HOW DOES THIS HELP
PROVIDE A PUT A ROOF OVER
ANYONE TELL OVER ANYONE'S HEAD
IN FACT THIS WILL SIMPLY TURN
MOBILE HOMES INTO VACATION AND
SHORT TERM RENTALS FROM SUB
LESSEES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COST OF
HOUSING ESPECIALLY IN COASTAL
CITIES THIS ASSEMBLY TURN INTO
A COTTAGE BUSINESS INDUSTRY FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE MONEY BECAUSE
THERE'S NO LIMITS. ALSO IF THIS
PASSES SO IN THE PRACTICE OF
MOBILE HOME RENTALS VERSUS
FORCING PEOPLE TO BUY HOMES THE
REASON WHY MANY HOME OWNERS
HAVE HOMES IS BECAUSE IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES WHEN
FORECLOSURES AND OTHER THINGS
HAPPEN AND PEOPLE JUST
ABANDONED HOMES WE'VE TAKEN
OVER IF THIS BILL PASSES IT
WILL SAY UNLESS WE ALLOW
SUBLETTING FOR EVERYONE. IF WE
TAKE OVER A HOME BECAUSE
SOMEONE LEFT IT ABANDONED WE'LL
JUST LEAVE IT VACANT BECAUSE IN
A LOT OF AREAS WE CAN'T SELL IT
WE'VE HAD PEOPLE THAT AT THIRTY
FIVE RENTAL HOMES IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES THERE NOW
DOWN TO THREE BECAUSE THE
MARKET OVER THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS WASN'T THERE. FOR THEM TO
SELL IT NOW THEY ARE. AFTER THE
OWNERS OF FOR TO DO TO THINGS.
BY GIVE MYSELF TIME OWNERS WILL
EITHER HAVE TO DO A SUBLETTING
POLICY FOR EVERYONE IN THE PARK
OR THE HAVE TO FORCIBLY SELL
OTHER PARK ON RENTALS WHICH
MEANS THAT MOBILE HOME PARKS
WILL BE ONLY FOR PEOPLE TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND YOU'LL NEVER
HAVE ANOTHER OWN PARK RENTAL
AGAIN WE DON'T THINK THIS IS
GOOD SUB WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
A GOOD POLICY AND WE THINK THAT
YOU'RE CONFLATING TWO CONCEPTS
RUNNING ON SUB LEASING AND FOR
THESE WE THINK THIS IS BAD
POLICY FOR HOUSING IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
OPERATOR FOR COULD PLEASE
ACKNOWLEDGE. JASON I CURRENT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME
PARK OWNERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHANGE CAN OCCUR
WITHOUT A SINGLE PAYER PROBE
SENTIMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT SIX
SIXTY ONE AND WILL INCREASE
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM REPRESENTS W.
NAY- IT'S APPLES AND ORANGES TO
COMPARE- A PART OWNER OF THE
THING OWN HOME TO A RESIDENTS
MEETING IN OWN HOME THE PARK
OWNER HAS AN OBLIGATION. TO THE
REST OF THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE-
AND THAT'S JUST NOT SOMETHING
THAT THEY SHARE WITH THE
RESIDENTS WOULD ALSO CHALLENGE
THE ASSERTION MADE THAT THE
BILL DOES NOTHING TO IMPEDE THE
RENTAL OF THE CAR GOING HOME TO
AN EMPLOYEE- YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WHAT THE MISTAKE ON APRIL
TWENTY FIRST EVEN THOUGH THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL DOES ALLOW
PARK OWNER TO BE USED. PULLING
AND TEARING- AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN A FEW WEEKS AGO
AFTER THAT THE FOLLOWING TO THE
BILL QUOTE- IT AND IT'S A
CRISIS IT TO AN EMPLOYEE RENTAL
AND YOU WERE PROHIBITED FROM
DOING SO COOL IF AN EMPLOYEE
HAS BEEN DESIGNATED AS AN
EMPLOYEE OF PARK MANAGEMENT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF OBTAINING A.
RENTAL OR SUBLEASE IN
PROHIBITION. LANGUAGES LINE
OPEN WHAT IS THE- DOES THE MEAN
TO. SOMEONE OF THE- TO OBTAIN
VENTURA. APPROACH THAT'S VERY
AND- IN REALITY. THE COURTS ARE
GOING TO HAVE MAKE THE TO. ANNA
PARKER EVERY THEY GO THERE WITH
JANET LEIGH LISA. OF HOME TO
EMPLOYEE IT'S IT IN THEIR
INTEREST IN THE INTEREST OF THE
COMMUNITY TO HAVE SOMEONE
LIVING ON SITE. WILL HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
VERY MUCH OPENING THEMSELVES UP
TO LITIGATION AND DOING SO. SO
AGAIN WE OPPOSE THE PRINCIPLE
THAT THE PREMISE OF THE BILL.
AND IN PARTICULAR THE FIRST
LANGUAGE WHICH WILL EFFECTIVELY
MAKE IT. IMPOSSIBLE FOR
CORPORATE TO RETURN A PHONE.
CALL GOING TO CLEAN OUT WEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NOT
GO TO. OF THE- THAT WISH TO SEE.
OF FOR IN SUPPORT THE BILL DID
NOT SEEN ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WAR AND- THE REMOTE
STATION. LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE WHO'S
SUPPORTING THE BILL. SURE SURE
SURE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST COMMENT. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENTS FROM NINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE I JUST
GOT THIS AND I AM A LITTLE BIT
FASTER. MY NAME IS TONY WALLACE
AND I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. HI
I'M A MOBILE HOME OWNERS. LIVE
IN THE PARK WITH TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MOBILE HOMES WE ARE
IN COURT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU RIGHT FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO POINT FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS ROGER JOHNSON I AM A MOBILE
HOMEOWNER THERE ARE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY RESIDENTS IN
MY PARK AND WE SUPPORT A. B. H.
SIX ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS NGUYEN SULK AT
BELMONT SHORES MOBILE ESTATES
IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED MOBILE HOME OWNERS HE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ANDREA MAY
FIELD I LIVE IN RANCHO BUENA
VISTA MOBILE THE STATE IN
PHANTOM ARENA CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
MOBILE HOMES AND OUR PARK AND
WE SUPPORT AB EIGHT SIX ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS ANNA ANDERSON I LIVE IN
SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA MY
MOBILE HOME PARK HAS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR SPACES
AND I SUPPORT AB. EIGHT SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
LINDA WINTERS ISLAND THE MODEL
MORRO BAY CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOBILE HOME OWNER IN A PARK
WITH FIFTY THREE MOBILE HOMES
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU RIGHT
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LOUIS COLE I LIVE IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK IN BOTH MY
CALIFORNIA WITH THE FIVE NINETY
NINE UNITS WE SUPPORT. EIGHTY
SIX EIGHT SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAN
BERMAN I AM A MOBILE HOMEOWNERS
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA THE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE RESIDENTS
OF OUR MOBILE HOME PARK ARE
IMPORTANT AB EIGHT ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY NINE
OF PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN MADISON I LIVE IN
CARPINTERIA CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOBILE HOMEOWNER IN A PARK WITH
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
RESIDENTS. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETEENTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK O'CONNELL
SAN JOSE FIFTY NINE PARKS
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU RIGHT
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JEFF DEAN WHO
STARSKY BRING MINE CALIFORNIA I
OWN A MOBILE HOME IN A PARK
WITH TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIX ONE.
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
LET'S NOT GO TO MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO THIS-
SEEN KNOWN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE
STATIONS OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW. ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO REGISTER OPPOSITION TO-
PLEASE SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PLANES FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CREAM THREE
C. ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- LET ME JUST ALSO
CONFIRM IT TOO WELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BEEN ARE YOU ACCEPTING
THE MOMENTS YESTERDAY GREAT
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. OUR MOTION OF THIS
FORD. IS MOTIONS ARE SECOND.
GREAT- AND WITH THAT MISTER
BENNETT IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND PERHAPS RESPOND TO ANY
OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN
RAISED THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO JUST
ASK YOU ALL TO CONSIDER THAT
YOU ARE SKILLED LEGISLATORS AND
YOU HAVE. I OFTENTIMES HEARD
THE OPPOSITION TO SOMETHING-
MAKE CONFUSING ARGUMENTS THAT I
DON'T ACCURATE ACCURATELY
REFLECT REALITY. AND I WOULD
OFFER TO YOU THAT'S WHERE THE
SUB LEASING ARGUMENT IN
OPPOSITION IS HERE. IF PARK
OWNERS THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THERE COULD BE AIRBNB SAID THEY
TO TICKET THE ALL THESE PARTS
COULD BE CONVERTED OVER- WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT. THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION OUT THERE
THAT IS SENIORS LIVING IN THESE
MOBILE HOME PARKS COUNTING ON
THIS. AND FUTURE SENIORS THAT
WILL NEED THIS OPTION. SO THE
FUNDAMENTAL ARGUMENT. IS I
BELIEVE THIS THIS IS NOT GOING
TO. ALLOW A COULD NOT GOING TO
BECAUSE ALL OF THE MOBILE HOME
PARKS TO BECOME AIRBNB. IF THE
PARK OWNERS DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN THEY SIMPLY MAKE THAT A
RULE. IT'S JUST WHEN THEY MAKE
THE RULE IT SHOULD APPLY TO
THEM AND THEIR UNIT ALSO. IF
YOU LIVE IN A MOBILE HOME PARK.
AND THERE'S YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
AND THE OTHER TENANTS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE IT AS BE AN
AIRBNB WHY SHOULD THE PARK OR
BE ABLE TO TAKE TAKE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT. AND BRING IN
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PARTY. BUT
THE BIG FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS
THIS. AND I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
THIS ENOUGH DO YOU WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE PARK OWNERS TO
CONTINUALLY BUY UP. THESE
MOBILE PLEASE MANUFACTURED
HOMES WHEN THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE AND DECREASE THE
STOCK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUT
THERE. BECAUSE THEY WILL HAVE
AND BE ABLE TO GET THE RULES TO
APPLY DIFFERENTLY WHEN IT COMES
AROUND STABILIZATION. OR DO YOU
WANT TO KEEP THESE UNITS
AVAILABLE THE PRECIOUS FEW
UNITS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT WHEN THAT
ELDERLY WOMAN THAT'S NINETY
THREE YEARS OLD PASSES AWAY
THAT MOBILE HOME PARK AT THAT
MANUFACTURED HOME. IS THEN SOLD
TO SOMEBODY ELSE THAT NEEDS
THAT THAT'S REALLY THIS
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE WHO IS GOING
TO HAVE THE INCENTIVE TO BUY
THESE HOMES I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
NOT INCENTIVIZE. THE PARK
OWNERS TO BUY UP A LARGER AND
LARGER PERCENTAGE OF THESE
MOBILE HOMES. VIBEKE BY BEING
ABLE TO CREATE. DIFFERENT RULES
FOR THEM- THEN APPLY TO THE
TENANTS IN THEIR PARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE WE FORTUNATE WITH
FORWARD AND MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS- SHE HI SHE I'D SAY ARE
TO NOW THEIR CHAIN NO GABRIEL.
KALRA KALRA I. KILEY KNOWN.
QUIRKS. QUICKSILVER I WICKS.
THANK WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- ACTUALLY
HAVE MISTER LEADERS OKAY FOR GO
TO HIM AND THEN WE- HAVE YOU.
PRESENT THE LAST FULL SO CALLED
FIVE THREE AB TEN SIXTY. MR LEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
AT FIRST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THIS WITH MY STUFF
ON IT. AB TEN SIXTY ONE WERE
PROTECT MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
FROM ARBITRARY UNFAIR WATER
SERVICE CHARGES. CURRENTLY MANY
RESIDENTS ARE CHARGING AND
BIGGEST WATER SERVICE FEE THAT
OFTEN INCREASES WITHOUT ANY
EXPLANATION. OVER HALF OF
MOBILE HOME HOUSEHOLDS EARN
LESS THAN FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND MANY
RESIDENTS ON FIXED INCOMES SO
THESE FEES CAN ADD UP. QUICKLY
BURDENSOME. I'LL BE EXCEPT MAKE
MADE AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL
ALLOW PARK OWNERS TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR HIGHER WATER
PRICES. THEY MAY. THEY MAY PAY
DO TWO TIERED BILLING. THE
MEMBER ALSO ALLOWED HELLO PARK
ON TO BILL RESIDENTS MANAGEMENT
OR THIRD COSTS ISSUED METER
READER. METER READING SENDING
OUT BILLS AND OTHER REASONABLE
EXPENSES WE LAND ON THESE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THEY ALIGNED
MOBILE HOME PARK. MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS WITH CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT ALREADY APPLY
TO HOME AN APARTMENT DOLLARS.
THAT MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS
PAID THEIR PROPORTIONAL SHARE
OF PARK. A PARK OWNERS WATER
CHARGES PLUS A REASONABLE
SERVICE AND MANAGEMENT FEE.
DESANCTIS FIND SUPPORT I HAVE
RECEIVED BILLS SEASON. REGIONAL
MANAGER FOR GIVE ALL AND BRUCE
STANTON OF LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
HIS ROLE AS WE ASK FOR YOUR
PRIVATE. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
THE OP TO THE MAIN WITNESSES
MISTER. M. STANTON. ABOUT FIVE-
OPEN. AFTER MY NAME IS JOSEPH
I'M I READ LEADER GSM ALL THE
STATE MAN HOME OWNERS WE ARE
NOT OR THAT HAS BEEN WORKERS
PEOPLE OF MODERN MEANS- SENIORS
AND AFTER IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN
MOBILE HOMES NOW YOU HOME
THROUGHOUT. FOR- OVER FIFTY.
GEOTHERMAL ALSO AB TEND TO. AND
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS WE SHOULD
PAY FOR THE WATER WE- AND WE
SHOULD PAY OUR WRITERS SHARE
SERVICE CHARGE THE WATER
COMPANY PARK OWNERS WHAT IS
FAIR IS ONE WAY SO PETER AND
PAUL OWNERS UP THE PRICE OF
WATER AND ON TERROR. TODAY MANY
PARKING ARE MORE SERVICE CHOI
TO EACH HOMES THROUGHOUT THE
PARK. OKAY MAKING UP THEIR OWN
CHARGES SOME PARTS OF MAKING
THE EXTRA OF THE MILLION A YEAR
JUST ALL WATER CHARGE. THANK
YOU. THANK. FOR GAS FOR A
SECOND ONE IS PLEASE. YES HI
THIS IS BRUCE STANTON GSM
ALLOWING SUPPORT I ACTUALLY
WOULD JUST ECHO EVERYTHING THE
FIRST WITH THE STATIC MEDICATED
BUT THEY'LL OFFER A QUESTION
THANK YOU. H. ONE WE NOW GO TO.
OUR MAIN WHEN AS AN OFFICE I
KNOW GOVERNOR IS STILL HERE.
THE COMMITTEE ROOM- BELIEVE
HE'S GOING TO HAVE ONE MINUTE-
AND THEN HAVE. YOU WILL TAKE TO
OKAY GREAT. HOLD ON TO GET MY
TIMER GOING. UNDER GOVERNOR
BABBITT WMA RESPECTFULLY NOW
MUST OPPOSE THIS BILL WE
ACTUALLY HAD ORIGINALLY WANTED
TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE MR LEE
AND THE SPONSORS THAT ACTUALLY
PROPOSED TO ADOPT THE CPUC
DECISION THAT'S BEEN LOST SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE REGULATING SUB
METERS MOBILE HOME PARK
RESIDENTS ALMOST EIGHTY TO
NINETY THOUSAND RESIDENTS
ACTUALLY- HOWEVER WHEN THEY
WROTE THE BILL THEY LEFT OUT
ONE LINE OF THIS P. U. DECISION
THAT HAD TO DO WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE DELIVERY
OF CHARGES FOR WATER. ALL
APPROVED BY THE CPUC WHAT WE
ASKED FOR WAS THAT ACTUALLY GO
TO ALL THE MUNICIPALITIES SO
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW WITH ALL OF
THESE FACTS AND ALL THESE
NUMBERS OR SUPPOSE THAT FACT
THAT THE SPONSORS BRING UP
WE'VE NEVER SEEN EVIDENCE ABOUT
TO BACK UP ANY OF THESE THINGS
AS A MATTER OF FACT THE WAY WE
LOOK AT THIS BILL NOW. THEY ARE
TAKING A WALK BILL FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT HAD TO DO
WITH ENCOURAGING APARTMENTS TO
PUT IN SUB METERS. OKAY
APARTMENTS ARE SMALL UNITS YOU
HAVE ABOUT EIGHT FEET FROM A
MASTER METER TO A SUB METER AND
A MOBILE HOME PARK YOU COULD
HAVE PIPING GOING ACROSS THE
ENTIRE PARK TO THE REASON WHY
RATES ARE DIFFERENT AND YOU
CAN'T COMPARE APARTMENTS MOBILE
AND PARKS'S DID YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET DELIVERY UNIT. IN
ADDITION MUNICIPALITIES FOR
YEARS HAVE BEEN APPROVING PASS
THROUGH CHARGES FOR MOBILE HOME
OWNERS TO BE ABLE TO RECOVER
THE READING OF THE METER THE
SERVICING OF THE METER AND THE
BILLING THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR THERE ARE NO ARBITRARY
CHARGES THAT THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSE WE ARE COMING ABOUT WMA
HAS BEEN SUPPORTING THAT WATER
IS NOT A PROFIT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE. WE DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU'RE TAKING APARTMENT BLOCK
AND THEN PUTTING IT OVER IN
MOBILE HOME LAW IF WE WANT TO
START LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
LAWS. AND HOW THEY APPLY TO
MOBILE HOMES MANUFACTURED
HOUSING WE'D BE GLAD TO PUT
ARBITRARILY CHERRY PICK
APARTMENT WATER. TO THEN PUT ON
MOBILE HOMES WE BELIEVE IS
WRONG AND WHEN OUR WATER
LAWYERS LOOK AT THIS I'M NOT AN
EXPERT THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS NOT A UTILITY
EXPERT MR LEE STAFFORD NOT
UTILITY EXPERTS YET THESE THREE
PARTIES ARE ALL WRITING UTILITY
LAW WHICH HAS TO DO WITH WATER
PAYMENT. IF THIS BILL PASSES NO.
MORE SUB METERS WILL EVER BE
PUT ON A NO THEIR MOBILE SPACE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE LOSE WHY.
WHICH MEANS A HIGH AND FIFTY.
SPACE ARE MORE THE STATE WHAT
CAN. CONTINUE TO USE WATER AT
THEIR LEISURE WHICH MEANS THAT
IF YOU'RE THE CONSERVER THAT
LIVE NEXT DOOR. ONE OF THESE
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS MAKES
LESS THAN FORTY THOUSAND A
YEAR. WHY SHOULD YOU PAY AN
INFLATED WATER BILL BECAUSE
THAT YOUR NEIGHBOR IS USING A
LOT OF WATER. WE BELIEVE THIS
YOUR BILL SHOULD BE HELD AND WE
SHOULD WORK ON IT'S WE CAN COME
UP WITH GOOD WATER POLICY. THAT
PROVIDE QUALITY WATER FOR THIS
WE ASK THAT THE BILL BE HELD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WANNA GO
TO JASON I KERN WHO IS ON THE
LINE. TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE. HOME
PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YET CHANGEMAKER.
ON BEHALF OF THE PEEING WE ARE
OF COURSE OPPOSED AND THEN AB
TEMPLATE LINE BUT WITH
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE CAN THAT THE-
AT LEAST IN PART ONE OUR MOST
CAN WITH TO WATER RATES BUT
FOR- THE BILL IS IN PROPOSED TO
ME IN WILL NOT ALLOW PARK TO
THE CAR THE FULL. OF OPERATING
IN MAKES THE BLADDER SYSTEM
THIRD THERE CAN SO AS YOU AS
YOU JUST HEARD MR GOVERNANCE
YOU KNOW UNLIKE APARTMENT
BUILDING A MOBILE PHONE. HASN'T
NEW OF WATER DISTRICT LINE
LATERALS AND STUFF LEADERS THAT
THEY HAVE TO OFFER THE A
MINIATURE DISTRICT UTILITY- AND
THE PARK IS WHICH FOR ME AN
THAT THAT COMES FUNDS IN TWO
NINETY. A MEMBER EXPAND PAINS
IN A YOU KNOW AT TURKEY JUST
FIFTEEN IN ABOUT- MANHATTAN'S
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THESE
ARE LARGE- NXP- UNDER FOR APART-
SO AT. ASSERTION MADE HERE
TODAY BY THE PROPONENTS AND ANY
ANALYSIS UP TO SOMEHOW TURNED
INTO PURE PROFIT THAT ACCURATE
IF YOU BELIEVE ME ONLY CAUGHT
THE PARKING SPACE THING IS FROM
THEIR MONTHLY UTILITY BILL BUT
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THE MONTHLY
UTILITY BILL CAPTURES THE
UTILITIES FIX CAR NOT THE
PARKS- SO WE BELIEVE IT'S
ENTIRELY REASONABLE FOR PARKS
YOU CAN USE THE CHARGES THAT
OUR PRESIDENT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE PAYING AS A BENCHMARK. WHAT
THEY THEMSELVES SHOULD SHOULD
BE ABLE TO COLLECT TO COVER
THESE COSTS IT IS NOT A CHARGE
THEN STEP BY THE PARKING SOUNDS
THEY HAVE TO LOOK TO THE
UTILITY FOR IT- SO FOR THESE
REASONS BECOMES PART OF THE
BILL I THINK I THINK PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED WON'T ALLOW
RECOVERING COSTS WE
UNFORTUNATELY OF THE MAIN OF
HOMES AND ARE. ASKING FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S
NOW TO. MEMBERS OF. THE WISH
TO- EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT OF TO
THIS BILL. C. KNOWN IN THE CA
ROOM THREE STATE. OPERATOR OF
COULD PLEASE. ALLOW MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THEY WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION
AND JUST THE FACT THAT THEY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
ABOUT FIFTEEN IN Q. OR TWICE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROGER
JOHNSON I LIVE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA. I AM A
MOBILE HOMEOWNER THERE ARE
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
RESIDENTS IN MY PARK WE ALL
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. TEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANKS
BAKER THANK YOU NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME OKAY AND
THURMOND I'M A MOBILE HOMEOWNER
IN CAMERA THE CALIFORNIA. ONE
IN THIRTY NINE RESIDENTS BOB
MOBILE HOME PARK- EACH FOR AB
ONE SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
LINDA NINE I'M A MODEL HOME
HOMEWORK IN STAYING CALIFORNIA
YEAH WE ARE SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TONY
WALLACE I LIVE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M A MOBILE
HOME OWNER. WE'RE IN A PARK
WITH TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MOBILE HOMEWE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY
TWO PLEASE CALL HAVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS NGUYEN HELLO. MY NAME
IS PRINCE ALL TIME THAT
PRESIDENT OF THE GENERAL
CHAPTER AT BELMONT SHORE PUBLIC
STATES IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED MOBILE HOME OWNERS HIS
DRUM RIGHT THE COURT. EIGHTY
TEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA
WINTERS I LIVE IN MORRO BAY
CALIFORNIA IN THEM I AM IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK WITH FIFTY
THREE MOBILE HOMES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TEN SIXTY ONE. THANK
YOU RIGHT NINETEENTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE NINE. MARK
O'CONNELL ST ALL DAY HOME OF
SOME OF THE LARGEST AMOUNTS OF
ADD ON CHARGES FOR WATER WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU I FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE. FIVE
FOUR. RIGHT FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LIZ AND CLARK
I LIVING COSTS THAT CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MOBILE HOMES AND OUR PARK.
AND YOU WANT. RIGHT FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
MAYFIELD IN SANTA MARIA
CALIFORNIA I LIVE IN RANCHO
BUENA VISTA MOBILE THE STATE
THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
MOBILE HOMES AND OUR PARK AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN MADDOX I LIVE IN
CARPINTERIA CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOBILE HOMEOWNER IN A PARK WITH
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
RESIDENTS. WE ARE ALL STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LOUIS CALL I LIVE IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK IN OJAI
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NINETY NINE
UNITS AND WE ALL STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TEN SIXTY ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JUDY PAVLIK I AM THE FOUNDER OF
THE SUNNYVALE MOBILE HOME PARK
ALLIANCE SENDING MAIL IS
LOCATED IN SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA THERE ARE THIRTEEN
PARTS OF THE LEVIN TELLS YOU
RESIDENTS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS MICHELLE MONNING
I AM A MOBILE HOME OWNER IN A
PARK IN ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
WITH FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
RESIDENTS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ROBERT VAN
CLEVE I LIVE IN RANCHO CORDOVA
IN AND THE RESIDENT OWNER OF A
MANUFACTURED HOME IN AND
REPRESENTING TO THE RESIDENTS
OF TO COMMUNITIES WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
HOUSEHOLDS WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ID BRITAIN
WITH THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS PATRICIA
NEXT I LIVE IN SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO CALIFORNIA I AM A
HOMEOWNER IN A PARK WITH TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO RESIDENTS I
AM SUPPORT OF THE A. B. TEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME'S LESLIE WESTBROOK I
LIVE IN CARPINTERIA CALIFORNIA
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY A
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS IN THE PARK
WITH TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
HOMES AND WE ARE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU LET'S NOT
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
C. KNOWN HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE STATION
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THE FACT THAT THEY OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TEN SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE TWENTY ANY
DISCUSSION MR COUNTY. I YEAH I
AGREE WITH WHAT- YOUR BILL
SEEKING TO DO IS REALLY WHY I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
ADDRESS THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED- WITH A BY THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ROOM TO
WORK THERE- ON NOT ADDRESSING
THOSE GOING FORWARD. I JUST
HIGHLY I WOULD LIKE TO ASK TURN
IT OVER TO BRUCE STANTON WAS
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES MALL TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE. MISTER STANTON.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WE HAVE TO REMEMBER HERE
THAT WATER DELIVERY IS FAR
DIFFERENT FROM THE ENERGY
DELIVERY OF GAS AND ELECTRIC IT
IS HEAVILY REGULATED BY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WATER IS NOT IS A MATTER OF
FACT A LITTLE OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO THE CPUC BEING TWITTER AT.
THIS VERY ISSUE ALONG WITH
OTHERS CONCLUDED THAT THEY
COULD NOT ADDRESS IT BECAUSE
WATER DELIVERY HAPPENS IT'S FAR
TOO MANY WAYS ON MY GAS
ELECTRIC YEAH USABLE SYSTEMS
PRIVATE WELLS AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN. THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS IN MOBILE HOME PARKS THESE
WATER SYSTEMS ARE CONSTRUCTED
IN PUT IT TO THE GROUND BEFORE
THE PARK OPENS. AND MOST ALL
PARKS IN CALIFORNIA DID NOT
START OUT BEING SET METER PARKS.
THE WATER LINE YOU'RE PUT IN
PERHAPS BY MUNICIPAL- WATER
COMPANIES PERHAPS BY THE PARK
OWNER IN ALL DIFFERENT MATTERS
OF SPEAKING WE DON'T KNOW. BUT
THE POINT IS THAT WHEN THOSE
SYSTEM DURING THE GROUND IN
THEIR NOT SO PETER IF THEY
BREAK THE PARK OWNER HAS TO FIX
THAT PERHAPS AND THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE COMPENSATED IS THROUGH.
INCREASED RATS THROUGH PASS
THROUGHS THAT ARE ALLOWED IN
LONG TERM LEASES. OR WHEN THEY
BRING ADMINISTRATIVE RAN
HEARINGS OR CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PASSED THROUGH HEARINGS IN
LOCAL RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS. WHEN THEY SUB
METER THE WATER NOTHING CHANGES
THEY THEY STILL ARE ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION FROM ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT SOURCES. SO STATE NOW
THAT IF THEY CAN'T REPLICATE
THE CUSTOMER CHARGE TO EVERY
SINGLE SPACE IN THE PARK.
MULTIPLYING WHAT THEY PAY BY
THE NUMBER OF SPACES THAT
THEY'RE UNABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR SYSTEMS IS JUST WRONG.
THAT THAT. JUST DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING. THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT WHEN PARK
MANAGEMENT. READ METERS THEY
ONLY HAVE TO WALK A FEW FEET
BETWEEN THE METERS TO DO SO.
THE ONLY ITEM REALLY THAT THE
PARK OWNER- IT BECOMES
RESPONSIBLE FOR ON A NEW BASIS
WOULD BE THE PETER ITSELF AND
THERE ARE MANY PARKS WHERE
RESIDENTS ARE ACTUALLY CHARGED.
THE COST TO INSTALL THE METERS
AS WELL. AND THEY PAY AGAIN CA
RATS CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PASS
THROUGHS WHEN RECORDS WILL
JURISDICTIONS TO THE PROVISIONS
THAT THOSE STATUTES ALLOW. ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE THIS
PROJECT THE UNFAIR REPLICATION
OF THESE CUSTOMER SERVICE
CHARGES. OR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONFLATE. THEM WRONGFULLY. THIS
SHARES LIKE ONE OF THE
WITNESSES ONCE FOR THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO I'M HAPPY
FOR YOU TO ASK IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ASK. TO RESPOND TO WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY. YEAH OWNERS OF
THE ONES WHO PUT IN THE SYSTEM
IS WHEN THE PARKS ARE BUILT
MUNICIPALITIES DON'T PUT IN THE
CPC DOESN'T PUT IT IN IF YOU
WANT TO GRANDFATHER IN THE OLD
SYSTEMS LIKE MISTER STANTON
JUST SAID AND GOING FORWARD FOR
NEW YOU COULD DO FINE
GRANDFATHER IN EVERY SYSTEM LET
THEM LIVE UNER THE NEW RULES
AND IF YOU WANT TO APPLY NEW
SEPARATE SUB METERING RULES TO
NEW SUBMARINE AND SUB METERS
THEN DO SO BUT MR STANTON
LITERALLY JUST SAID BUT ALL OF
THESE CHARGES CAN BE RECOVERED
BY OWNERS. THROUGH A CURRENT
PROCEDURES WHICH ARE GOVERNMENT
APPROVED PROCEDURES SO THERE
ARE NO ARBITRARY CHARGES THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SAYING IN THE
END AT THE SUPPOSITION OF THE
BILL HE LITERALLY JUST ADMITTED
THAT ALL OF THE CHARGES FOR
PASS THROUGHS CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS ARE PROVEN RIGHT
CONTROL- YOU GET THE
MUNICIPALITIES TO APPROVE IT SO
ALL OF THESE CHARGES ARE PROVED
THERE ARE NO ARBITRARY RATES
THAT OWNERS JUST TACK ON TO
BILLS ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
READ THE SEVEN METRE BILL THE
SUB METER AND SERVICE THE
SYSTEM WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN
THE UTILITY SYSTEM IF YOU WANT.
GET US OUT OF THE WATER SYSTEM
HAVING AN MISS APART
MUNICIPALITIES AND SI PC TAKE A
SOBER AND GET US OUT LIKE YOU
DOING ON THE TRICITY THAT WOULD
BE GREAT AND HAVE THE RESIDENTS
DIRECTLY SERVED BUT UNTIL THAT
HAPPENS YOU CAN'T JUST
PROPORTIONALLY MAKE AN OWNER
LOSE MONEY ON THE DELIVERY OF
WATER FOR SYSTEMS HAD. IN PLACE
FOR THIRTY FORTY AND FIFTY
YEARS. THANK YOU SO I YEAH I
TAKE IT IS YOUR INTENT WAS
REALLY NOT TO IMPOSE THAT SORT
OF BURDEN ON- ON THE OWNER BUT
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO PROTECT
THAT. THE RESIDENT HERE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT. OVER
CHARGE SO I MEAN THAT YOU KNOW
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT I JUST. I ENCOURAGE- YOU
KNOW BOTH SIDES TO. MAKE SURE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE HERE AND
THAT THEY- COST RECOVERY IS- IS
ALLOWED TO THE EXTENT THAT IT
SHOULD BE. HI COMMENTS MISTER
MISTER. SO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE GRAZED HER ANKLE
CONCERNS I HAVE AND I HAVE A
UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
WATER SYSTEM ISSUE AND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUTSIDE THE
METER AND INSIDE THE METER WITH
THE MOBILE HOME PARK AS WELL AS
APARTMENTS CONDOMINIUMS TOWN
HOMES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
ASSEMBLY HEARING ISSUE GOES
BEYOND WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A GOES- INTO TIERED WATER
RATES. DAYS THAT WHEN THEY BILL
THIRTY SIX DAYS INSTEAD OF
THIRTY DAYS AND DON'T CHANGE
THE ALLOCATION AMOUNT- THAT CAN
LEAD TO AS MUCHAS A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR OVER PAYMENT FOR
RESIDENTIAL PEOPLE HOWEVER WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS EXPENSIVE AND
IT DOES NEED TO BE CONSTANTLY
REPAIRED AND RIGHT NOW THE
MOBILE HOME OWNERS THE OWNERS.
HAVE TO SOMEHOW REACHING THAT
ANGER AND IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND CHARGING
MORE THAN WHAT IS NECESSARY YOU
KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING I CAN GET
BEHIND THE TRYING TO ELIMINATE
IT AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY
WOULD GET THE MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO RECOUP THAT OTHER THAN DOING
MASSIVE ASSESSMENTS. ON PEOPLE
WHEN. THEY HAVE TO DO A FIFTY
SIXTY SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
REPAIR AND I DON'T THINK THE
MOBILE HOME OWNERS- WOULD TAKE
KINDLY DO THAT EITHER- SO THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE THOSE
INTERESTING ISSUES WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
GETTING RIPPED OFF MAYBE ON ONE
HAND BUT AT THE SAME TIME- YOU
KNOW THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES THERE ARE LARGE AND- AND
THE WAY THE SYSTEM IS SET UP
RIGHT NOW THEY NEED TO TRY TO.
YOU KNOW HAVE HAVE A
MAINTENANCE FUNDS FOR THAT AND-
IF THEY HAVE H. AWAY FEES OR
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT'S WHERE A
LOT OF TIMES EVERYTHING GETS
PUT INTO- SO- IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THIS IS. YOU KNOW WATER MEET
CHARGE I THINK THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE THERE TO DO SO. SIDE
I'M I'M A BIT WAIT TO SEE
WHAT'S WHAT IT IS THAT- IF YOU
HAVE IF YOU CAN ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THESE OTHER ISSUES-
BEFORE I CAN SUPPORT IT FOR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. LET ME ASK
THE AUTHOR IF YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ANY COMMENTS AND
CLOSE YES I'LL CLOSE WITH US
SAYING THANK YOU MR SAJID THANK
YOU FOR CALLING FOR YOUR A VERY
VALID CONCERNS LIKE OUR BILL IS
NOT TO MAKE IT SO THAT. BURKE
OWNERS CAN NO LONGER RECUPERATE
FAIRLY THE COSTS OF UP KEEPING
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NOT
THE GOAL OF THE BILL. I THINK
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WORKED
ON WITH THE COMMITTEE MAKE IT
MUCH MORE CLEAR IN THAT. IN
THAT REGARD. WE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. TO DRESS OF THESE
CONCERNS LIKE THE TIERED WATER
BILLING SYSTEM. AND BEING
REIMBURSED FOR OTHER MANAGEMENT
COST. AT THE TUNE OF EITHER
FOUR DOLLARS SEVENTY FIVE CENTS
PER MONTH OR- 25% OF THE BILL
WHICHEVER IS LOWER. I MEAN AND
IF WE LOSE TO YOU KNOW THESE
COSTS CAN REALLY STACK UP
RIGHT. BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FAIRLY ABLE TO MAKE
IT SO THAT MOBILE ARKEMA'S. CAN
MAINTENANCE SYSTEMS AND PROVIDE
WATER TO OLDER RESIDENTS IN
THERE WITHOUT. HAVING ARBITRARY
FEES THAT SOME OF. OUR SOME OF
OUR- CALLERS COMMENT AND TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY COULD BE
EGREGIOUS. AND UNFAIR. I NIGHT
AND I DO BELIEVE THE OPPOSITION
THEY SAY YOU KNOW THEY DO. NOT
WANT TO BE THERE IS A
PROFITEERING OFF OF PEOPLE'S
WATER BILLS. AND I THINK THIS
BILL SIMPLY DOES THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING RIPPED OFF. AND MAKE SURE
IS THERE'S A BALANCE THAT
PEOPLE SO MAKING INFRASTRUCTURE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IPHONE AND WILL CONTINUE
WORKING. WITH OPPOSITION. TO
KEEP. TRACK OF IT ALL. THANK
YOU BRING BY TO THE COMMITTEE I
JUST WANT TO SAY THE AUTHOR
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS I THINK- WORLD TRY TO
STRIKE THAT RIGHT BALANCE. I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WANTS TO.
ENSURE WANT TO SEE RENTERS
FACING EXORBITANT WATER SERVICE
CHARGES BUT WE ALSO. KNOW THAT
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT OWNERS
ARE RECEIVING. UNFAIR SERVICE
CHARGES FOR WHAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING- APPRECIATE YOU
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS TO MOVE IT
I THINK CLOSER TO A BOUNCE.
OPPOSITE THINK THERE'S STILL A
BIT MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BUT- I KNOW YOU ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO STRIKE
THAT RIGHT BALANCE AND- WITH
YOU TAKING THE MOMENTS THAT WE
HAVE ASKED FOR THIS COMMITTEE
I'M- PREPARED TO SUPPORT.
MOVING THIS FORWARD- LET ME
ASK. MR ANY OTHER COMMENTS
BECAUSE OUR MOTION WITH THIS
BEFORE. THEIR SECOND. SECOND OF
MADAM SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED IT CHILLED
BY CHIU ICE AIRTEL VOTING SEE
OUR TURNOUT VOTING GABRIEL
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
COOK SILVA. COOKS OF THE ICE
WICKES WICKES I THANK YOU BILLS
OUT. WITHOUT HER FINAL ITEM IS-
FILE ITEM TO AB NINE SEVEN
EIGHT PRESENTED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE MS CREEK SILVA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND WE ARE NOT IN THE EVENING
YET SO THAT IS A GOOD THING I
JUST WANT TO START BY MAKING
SOME GENERAL COMMENTS ABOUT
HOUSING WE ARE THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS
WE KNOW. HOUSING HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE LAST
DECADE FOR SOME PEOPLE THEY
WOULD BY WHETHER IT BE A SMALL
HOME OR- MOBILE HOME IN CASE
AND BELIEVE THAT. THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM OF OWNING THEIR
HOME IN RETIRING WOULD BE SAFE.
AND YET WE HAVE SEEN THINGS
CHANGE DRAMATICALLY. ALL OF US
WORK UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
WALK THE STREETS OF THE GRID
HERE AND SEE RIGHT BEFORE OUR
EYES. SOME OF THE MOST
DEVASTATING IMAGES THAT YOU
COULD SEE ACROSS THE WORLD
WHICH ARE LITERALLY PEOPLE
LYING ON THE STREETS. SOME WITH
THE SLEEPING BAG SOME WITH
NOTHING AROUND THEM AND SOME WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW MENTALLY IF
THEY ARE ALIVE OR NOT.
LITERALLY UNLESS WE GO UP TO
THEM. AND CHECK. AND THIS IS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THIS IS NOT
EXCLUSIVE TO SACRAMENTO IT'S
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL
CAME. TO ME LAST SESSION WHEN
IN MY HOMETOWN OF FULLER TEN.
THE LA PAZ MOBILE HOME WAS
BOUGHT BY OF. OWNER A NEW OWNER
AND RENTS WERE RAISED CLOSE
219% THIS PARTICULAR MOBILE
HOME PARK SITS ON LAND IN
FULLERTON AND ANAHEIM SO IT WAS
BOTH. CITIES ISSUE THERE WAS A
LOT OF DISCUSSION AT THE LOCAL
CITY COUNCIL OF WHAT COULD BE
DONE AND HERE AT THE STATE WE
WERE IN FACT LOOKING AT A RANGE
RENT STABILIZATION BILL AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER. THAT
BILL DID PASS BUT MOBILE HOMES
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN IT. LAST
YEAR WE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
TRY TO BRING FORWARD SOME TYPE
OF. SOLUTION FOR THE THIS NOT
ONLY THIS MOBILE HOME BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE PEOPLE UP
HERE WHO DO THEIR JOBS WELL
WHETHER THEY'RE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
OR LOBBYISTS AND MANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE OPPOSED TO MY
BILL ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
AN EXCELLENT JOB ADVOCATING FOR
THE PEOPLE THEY REPRESENT THEY
REPRESENT. WHETHER THEY BE THE
MOBILE HOME OWNERS AND MY JOB
IS TO ADVOCATE FOR THE PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY AND TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN. EVERYTHING I
CAN TO TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOUSED HOUSE WE ALREADY
HAVE AN ISSUE OF THOSE WHO ARE
NOT HOUSED AND WE ARE
STRUGGLING WE SAT HERE FOR
HOURS ON THURSDAY WITH SO MANY
BILLS TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS
AND YET WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOUSED WE STILL DON'T HAVE
A SOLUTION TO KEEP THEM HOUSED.
SO MY BILL IT IS NOT A SIMPLE
BILL IT'S COMPLEX I KNOW
SOMETIMES WE SAY IT'S JUST A
SIMPLE BILL AND THE TRUTH IS
THIS ISN'T A SIMPLE BILL IT IS
A DIFFICULT SUBJECT WE'RE
PASSIONATE PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES. WANT TO SEE A RESULT AND
I BRING THIS FORWARD AGAIN I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE AS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
CHANGE A BILL THAT STARTS IT AS
A DIFFICULT BILL AND WE ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS- THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED IN AN EFFORT TO
BUILD UPON THE PORTENT POLICY
DISCUSSIONS THAT TOOK PLACE.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN RELATED TO
RENT STABILIZATION BY EXTENDING
THEM TO MOBILE HOME OWNERS. THE
MAJORITY OF MOBILE HOMEOWNERS
RENT THE LAND THAT THE HOME
RESIDES ON. JUST AS WE HAVE
RENTS HAVE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED STATE WIDE MOBILE
HOME OWNERS ARE ALSO FACING
DRASTIC RENT INCREASES FROM
PARK OWNERS. HOW OVER MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING RENT INCREASES
FIND THEMSELVES IN VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS FIRST
MOBILE HOMES ARE NOT. AS THE
WORLD THE WORD IMPLIES MOBILE.
THEY ARE NOT. ALMOST NONE OF A
MORE MOVE LET'S FACE IT THEY'RE
NOT MOBILE. MOBILE HOME OWNERS
JUST LIKE TRADITIONAL
HOMEOWNERS PAY MORTGAGE ON THE
HOME THEY ALSO MUST PAY FOR
REPAIRS AND MAINTENANCE AS WELL
AS HOME TAXES MANY MOBILE HOME
OWNERS ARE SENIORS VETERANS AND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ON A
FIXED INCOME. THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING ARE OFTEN IN LOW WAGE
JOBS AND OTHERS RELY ON SOCIAL
SECUITY INCOME NOW LET ME GO
BACK TO THE FULLER TO AN
EXAMPLE. WE HAD PEOPLE COME TO
THE FULLERTON CITY COUNCIL.
THAT LIVE IN THOSE MOBILE
HOMES. AND TALK ABOUT WITHOUT
EIGHTY YEAR OLD. VETERANS
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON DIALYSIS MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE RIGHT NOW ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS SO A 19% RENT
INCREASE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE AND
DO THE MATH THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS BEYOND THEIR SOCIAL
SECURITY. SO IN SHORT. I'VE
INTRODUCED TO THIS BILL FOR
RENT STABILIZATION BUT I'VE
NARROWED IT. SO INSTEAD OF IT
APPLYING TO THE ENTIRE STATE IT
WOULD APPLY TO. MOBILE HOME
PARKS THAT AREN'T WHO
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL AS FAR AS
WE KNOW FULLERTON AND ANAHEIM
ARE THE ONLY ONES BUT I BELIEVE
WE THERE ARE A FEW OTHR
EXAMPLES THAT THE OPPOSITION
WILL NOTE TODAY WE HAVEN'T BEEN
GIVEN THAT INFORMATION BUT I DO
WANT TO BE FAIR THIS IS FOR
MOBILE HOME. PARKS THAT ARE IN
TWO JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
CONNECTED. SO IN OUR CASE. WE
HAVE FULLERTON AND ANAHEIM AND
IT'S THEY RUN ACROSS CITY LINES
BUT THERE COULD BE A FEW MORE
BUT THAT IS THE NARROWING OF
THE BILL THE NARROWING IS TO
APPLY TO THIS VERSUS THE ENTIRE
STATE AS WE BROUGHT FORWARD.
LAST YEAR. BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS I WILL COMMIT
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION BUT LET ME BE CLEAR
THE OPPOSITION THAT WE HAVE
TODAY IS THE OPPOSITION WE HAD
LAST YEAR. AND SIMPLY STATED I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO GET.
THE OPPOSITION REMOVED BECAUSE
THAT IS THEIR JOB. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE DOING
IT EXTREMELY WELL SO I WILL
STOP THERE AND INNER DO SO OUR
WITNESS. WE COULD GO TO THE TO
ME WITNESSES AND SUPPORT MS THE
PAPER MAREZ- REPRESENTING THE
CITIES OF ANAHEIM AND FULLERTON
AND THAT BRIGHT ACOSTA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. TO THE
OPERATOR. YES TO PAY FINES OPEN
I DO NOT SEE BRAINCHILD AND.
WHEN WE START WITH MR MARIS.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU HELLO.
OKAY YES BUT MY NAME IS A VERY
MERITS AND I DO LIVE IN A
TELEVISED I LIVED ON THE
ANAHEIM SIDE- WE WERE
APPROXIMATELY- ALMOST THREE
YEARS AGO BOUGHT BY WHAT HAS
BEEN KNOWN AS THEIR PREDATORY
BUYER OF MOBILE HOME PARKS.
IBAD MOBILE HOME PARKS UP AND
RAISES THE RENT ON SENIOR
CITIZENS UNTIL THEY CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE THERE- AS
HE DID IN HUNTINGTON CLIFFS
AND- AND MADE AT THAT TIME OVER
A HUNDRED PEOPLE HOMELESS. AND
WE BASICALLY ARE GOING TO THE
SAME THING HERE NOW- MY VET HAS
GONE FROM A SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS FROM WHEN HE BOUGHT THE
PART IN IT'S GOING TO BE TWELVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY IN OCTOBER.
SO IT'S ALMOST DOUBLED I AM ON
SOCIAL SECURITY AND ALSO HAVE
LEUKEMIA AND MY MEDICAL IS NOT
FULLY COVERED SO I MEAN I HAVE
TO MAKE A DECISION AT SOME
POINT OF WHETHER OR NOT I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE. MY
TREATMENTS ARE OF COURSE THE
HOUSE. I'M MORE APART AS AS
SHARON IT'S THAT. OF A SAID
IT'S- APPOINTED BY TWO CITIES-
WE HAVE GREAT DIFFICULTY THINGS
DNE HAVE TO GO. THE CITY
MEETINGS HAVE TO GO TO TWO
DIFFERENT HOUSING OFFICES WE
HAVE TO GO TO TWO DIFFERENT
CITY COUNCIL. WE HAVE TO GO TO
TWO DIFFERENT PLACES WHENEVER
WE NEED ANYTHING DONE SO
NOTHING EVER IS. YOU KNOW
SIMULTANEOUS OR WORKING WELL
FOR US- THE BIGGEST PART OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE CITY ARE ANAHEIM
RESIDENTS. AND IT CITY OF
ANAHEIM LITERALLY HAS NOT
OFFERED ANY HELP AT ALL TO THE
SENIORS IN THIS PART.
REPUBLICANS HAVE OFFERED MORE
HELP. ANAHEIM'S YEAH HI PEOPLE
CANNOT GET THREE MEALS ON
WHEELS THE FOURTEEN PEOPLE CAN
GET ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR FREE
MEALS ON WHEELS. WE ARE
COUNTIES HAD TO OPEN A- PARK
ENTRY HERE I CLICKED ENTRY. AND
WE NEED FIFTY SIX PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW EVERY WEEK WITH FOOD THAT I
GO TO DIFFERENT PLACES TO PICK
UP. BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT MANY
PEOPLE THAT CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO EAT. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO PAY THEIR RENT- WHEN
YOU'RE PAYING A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR ITS BASE
METAL. AND YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
WHEN YOU'RE EIGHTY YEARS OLD
IT'S EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS THIS
IS A PROBLEM. THERE'S A REAL
BIG PROBLEM. WE TRIED TO WORK
WITH OUR LANDLORD. AND WHAT HE
DID WAS GET TEN YEAR LEASES FOR
EVERYBODY THAT LOCKED THEM INTO
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF INCREASES
THE CAN'T BE PAID FOR. AND
AGAIN IT'S ALMOST LIKE THAT'S
THE PLAN FOR JUST MAKING SURE
WE GET FIFTEEN YEARS OUT AND
THEN AFTER WE'RE ALL GONE YOU
CAN BUILD CONDOS. WHICH IS AT
OF HOTEL IS WHAT HE DID IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH- WE HAVE A ONE
SITUATION THAT I REALLY LIKE TO
SHARE. WITH YOU THAT BOTHERS ME
THE MOST. WE A NEIGHBOR MINE TO
UP TO HAVE TO STAY ON. HIS
COMMITMENT. CHAU OR HER CLOSE.
IT AND SHE HAD A MOBILE HOME
THERE. WHEN MR SO. THE NEW OWN
BOUGHT THE PARK HE RAISED EVERY.
MATCH TO THE POINT SHE COULD
KEEP UP SHE GOT THE- AND HE
OFFERED THE ALL SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO. OUT THEY WERE ALL
BEHIND IN. AND GO TO LOSE THEIR-
SHE BOUGHT HERE. BECAUSE THIS
IS A- NEXT AVAILABILITY. HE
HAVE TO BE WE DON'T HAVE LAKE
DON'T HAVE. IT'S A- PARK. IN
WHEN SHE WHEN HE RIGHT HERE SHE
THOUGHT SHE'D BE SAID. FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS. THIS MAN HAS
BOUGHT THE PARK. OKAY SO LOOKED
PREDICT ASIDE WE CAN'T OF.
THESE INCREASE. SHE FINALLY
DECIDED SHE WOULD JUST GO TO
SELL HE WAS. IT HER. PAYMENTS
AND THEIR- TO PAY OFF. THE
MONEY WAS THIRTY. WHICH SOLD
OUT OF THE- AND- SHE'S OKAY
PLACE ON A- WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
WHEN SHE WAS SO STRESSED OUT
AND SO AFRAID OF LOSING HER
HOME AGAIN. WE FOUND HER DEAD
TO THE FOLLOWING SUNDAY MORNING
IN HER HOUSE BECAUSE SHE JUST.
DIDN'T CARE ANYMORE AND DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE THE WILL TO FIGHT
ANYMORE. WHAT'S THE WORST IN
HERE PEOPLE THAT ARE SO
DESPERATE. PEOPLE THAT THAT
THAT ARE SICK THEY'RE HAVING
HEART ATTACKS THE PARAMEDICS-
IN HERE EVERY DAY BECAUSE OF
THE STRESS THE PEOPLE ARE
FEELING. WHERE DO YOU GO WHEN
YOU'RE HOMELESS AT EIGHTY IN
YOUR ON DIALYSIS WHEN YOU'RE
HOMELESS ON EIGHTEEN A WITH
EASY AND YOU NEED A WHEELCHAIR.
I MEAN THERE'S NO PLACE TO GO
THERE'S NO SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
ANYMORE THERE'S NO LOW INCOME
HOUSING FOR SENIORS ANYMORE. WE
NEED TO STAY IN OUR HOMES WE
NEED SOME HELP WE NEED
SOMETHING TO KEEP PREDATORY
BUYERS FROM JUST COMING IN HERE
AND TAKING THE LETTERS OUT FROM
UNDER US BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOWHERE ELSE TO GO. IN IN OUR
SITUATION IS. IF. I CAN ASK
ARAMBULA PLEASE. OKAY WE'RE IN
TWO DIFFERENT YOUR SIX WE TWO
DIFFERENT SETS OF FROM. AND WE
NEED HELP. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET ME NOW GO TO THE
SECOND WITNESSES MR COST ON THE
LINE. I DON'T SEE HIM DIE OPEN
CURRENTLY OKAY F. NOT LET'S GO
TO THE MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- MR CHRIS WEISS SAKE
OF REPRESENTING THE WESTERMAN
FACTOR HOUSING COMMUNITIES-
HERE IN PERSON. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS REPAIR MEMBERS
TO PLEASURE TO SEE YOU- FIRST
OF ALL WMA WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT TO. ADDRESS
THAT HOWEVER THIS BILL IS NOT
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT. THIS
BILL LIMITS RENT INCREASES TO
MOBILE HOME PARKS ACROSS TO
CITY LINES 23% PLUS 5% OF CPI.
AS OUR OPPOSITION LETTER STATES
MOBILE HOME PARK SHOULDN'T BE
HELD TO DIFFERENT STANDARDS.
THEN OTHER RENTAL HOUSING UNITS
BARTENDERS HAVE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PART. THEY HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THEIR PARK AMENITIES
THEY LIVE BY THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR HEART
PARKS PROVIDE A SAFE AND SECURE
HOUSING FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE. HOUSING IS A KEY
PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED
MORE OF IT. WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE DEVELOPED. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE MORE WE NEED
MORE FOR HER PORTABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS IF WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE MORE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
BUT NINE SEVENTY EIGHT WON'T
HELP THAT SITUATION. AT LEAST
UNDER FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT
THE AUTHOR RECOGNIZED THERE
WOULD VETO VACANCY DEACON KROLL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT RESIDENTS
ARE STRUGGLING BUT WE HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS THAT PARK
OWNERS ARE STRUGGLING AS WELL.
WE HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND SECURE HOUSING FOR
RESIDENTS. BUT THIS AB NINETY
SEVENTY EIGHT SETS A PRECEDENT
THAT WILL MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO CONTINUE
OPERATING OUR PARKS. THAT MAKE
PEOPLE DIFFER FOR THE PANDA.
THANK YOU AND I JUST ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT. THAT THIS BILL
DIRECTLY CONTRADICTS AND WILL
BLOW UP A BILL THAT YOU JUST
VOTED ON- THE BENNETT BELL AGE
SIXTY ONE. AND FOR THAT AND
MANY OF THE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINE JASON
OCCURRED REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SENATE JACKSON
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE NPA.
YEAH WHAT IT LOOKS START IGNORE
THANK NOT LOOKING WHAT THE
DOCTOR SAID THE OUT THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT THE PROVISION
IN THE BILL THE DEAL BEING
SPENT AT LEAST HAS BEEN
NARROWED TO. PARKS IN TWO
DIFFERENT CITIES THAT'S SAID-
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED WITH WITH THE
PRESIDENT THAT WE'RE SPENDING-
WHICH INCLUDES OBVIOUSLY A
LOWER ABOUT BRITAIN CREASE AND
WHAT WE- APPROPRIATE FOR
APARTMENTS AND OTHER TYPES OF
HOUSING. BUT IT IN ADDITION TO
THAT- SOMETHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM W. MAY TOUCHED
ON WHICH IS THANK YOU CAN BE
CONTROL SO TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN
PERSPECTIVES- CRITICAL SYSTEM
VERY DIFFERENT ANIMAL- IN IN
THE CONTEXT OF A MOBILE HOME
PARK AND IT IS TO ANY OTHER
TYPE OF HOUSING IN THE STATE
BECAUSE- RESIDENTS. BY AND
LARGE OWN THEIR HOMES AND
SIMPLY WITH THE SPACE BENEATH
IT AND SO- EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT DEFERS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- ON WHETHER OR NOT
TO ALLOW. THE FACE SPACE FOR IT
TO BE RESET TO THE MARKET RATE
UPON VACANCY THAT'S ANOTHER WAY
OF SAYING THANK YOU THINK ANY
CONTROL- SO WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND
THIS IS A THOUSAND NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT WE AS PARK
OWNERS CLAIM IT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN LITERATURE AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH.
YOU AND HAVE WITH WITH MANY OF
YOUR STAFF IT'S ESTABLISHED IN
JURISDICTIONS WITH THINKING
THINKING CONTROL. WELL YOU'VE
REALLY ACCOMPLISHED DISAPPEARED
ENTRY TO THE SECOND GENERATION
OF PARKER- WHAT WHAT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT I THINK THAT THE
HOMEOWNER. WHO WHOSE FACE IS
RENT CONTROL WELL I ACTUALLY
DIDN'T DO IT- IT HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE FEEDING TO
THE PERSON THEY'RE SELLING TO
WILL BE ENABLED SO THAT IN THE
PRICE OF THEIR HOME. SO WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING WHEN WE
WHEN WE ALLOW CAN'T CONTROL 2%
IS WE'RE INFLATING THE COST OF
HOUSING- AND IN FACT FOR THE
MOST AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
STATE- AT BEYOND. THAT- WHAT.
CAN WE DON'T THE- MINUTES OF
CONFINED FROM. DEVELOPMENT IN
COURT. MANY PARK- WE- DID THAT
AMENDMENT COUPLE SICKENING.
WOULD APPLY RENT CONTROL HOMES
PARK. ARE STATEWIDE THEY SAID A
DIFFERENT TRAIN AND GET LIEU.
FOR TENANTS LIVING IN SAME. AND
BACK THE- WELL AND OTHERS WE
REMAIN TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
LINE. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MORE
MOMENT WHEN WE GET ON THAT MY
NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS BRIAN GUSTO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE THAT PERSON
DID REMOVE THEMSELVES I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CAN NOW GO TO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO OPPOSE THE BILL AND STATE
THAT KNOWN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM NO ONE ON THE
REMOTE STATIONS- IF THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE. THAT WISHES
TO STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
THEIR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AP AT NINE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM GREETS HIM TO HAPPEN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANKS LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY COMMENTS.
OUR MOTION WITH THIS BEFORE
THEIR SECOND. THIS ONE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR DILIGENCE
ON THIS AS THE LEAD AUTHORED AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO- I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE HERE WE-
FRANKLY- THIS WAS IT A
CHALLENGING TOPIC A COUPLE
YEARS AGO IF IT HAD BEEN UP TO
ME. WE WOULD HAVE FIGURED OUT
HOW WE EXTENDED THE SAME
PROTECTIONS OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO TO MOBILE HOMEOWNERS BUT-
WE'VE DECIDED TO DEFER THAT TO
THIS DISCUSSION I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN REALLY DILIGENT AND-
TRYING TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
APPRECIATE YOUR DEEP ENGAGEMENT
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
WITH OUR STAFF ON THIS. AND FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE PUT FORTH IN A VERY
MUCH THINK THAT- DURING THIS
HOUSING CRISIS AND RENTAL
CRISIS WE NEED TO GIVE ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER YOU LIVE IN A MOBILE
HOME OR NOT- SOME SENSE OF
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU. YOU
PROPOSED A NARROWING THE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO- TO REALLY TRY
TO WORK IT OUT OF FOR SOME OF
THESE PARKS IN YOUR DISTRICTS
WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
OF COURSE. LIKE I NEED TO
EXPLAIN- MY ISSUE IS NUMBER ONE
THIS IS A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
ISSUE AND FINANCIAL WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S HUGE AND
IT'S OUR OWN MAKING YEARS YEARS
YEARS IN THE MAKING. AND SO
THESE TYPE OF THINGS ARE GOING
TO NECESSARILY SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS ARE JUST BANDAIDS THAT
WERE THROWN OUT TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE- YOU KNOW IT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I YOU KNOW I
REALLY FEEL LIKE. THE LOCAL
AGENCIES NEEDED YOU KNOW STEP
UP AND HELP THOSE PEOPLE- WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES IN AND DOES A
19% INCREASE IN THEIR RANTS.
YOU KNOW THAT SOMETHING FOR
THAT'S WHAT THOSE WE'RE GONNA
PUT THE LOCAL PEOPLE TO WORK
CITY COUNCIL PEOPLE ARE USED TO
BE ONE OF THEM- THAT'S OUR JOB.
AND SO AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM
WHEN I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING
TO NARROW THIS DOWN STEP BUT
IT'S STILL KIND OF A BLANKET
APPROACH. ARE THEY CAN BE. IT
CAN BE PRETTY BACKED BY
SOMEBODY ELSE ON TO IT AND
THAT'S I GUESS THAT'S REALLY
JUST WHAT MY CONCERN IS- WE
NEED THE LOCAL PEOPLE TO STEP
UP FOR AND OUR JOB IS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE DID WRONG. TO
CREATE A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
BECAUSE WE CREATED A MONSTER
PROBLEM IN THE SUPPLY SIDE WE.
NEED TO FIX IT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. I'M JUST GONNA
SAY TO THAT FOR A MOMENT- I
THINK EVERYONE IN THIS
COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS WE HAVE A
SUPPLY DEMAND PROBLEM- THE
CHALLENGES WE ARE WE ARE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID MASS
EVICTIONS AND WHAT WE DID A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WITH AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WHAT WE'VE
DONE AND THIS PANDEMIC AS FAR
AS PROVIDING EVICTION
PROTECTIONS AS WE SAID WE HAVE
A SUPPLY DEMAND PROBLEM BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT. HOW WE PREVENT MASS
EVICTIONS- CERTAINLY AGREE THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES NEED TO STEP UP
THERE THE REALITY IS WE'RE
DOING THIS BECAUSE A LOT OF
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVEN'T AND I
BELIEVE I DON'T WANNA SPEAK FOR
THE AUTHOR- BUT THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS NARROWED THIS SO
INCREDIBLY- IT NARROWLY TO A
COUPLE OF JURISDICTIONS IN HER
DISTRICT RATHER THAN TRYING TO
APPLY THE STATE WIDE. IS A
RECOGNITION THAT TO- THAT THAT
MAYBE WE FIGURE THIS OUT FOR
THOSE JURISDICTIONS AND WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT ELSE COULD
APPLY IF THIS WERE I THINK A
STATE WIDE APPLICATION I THINK
THAT YOUR ARGUMENT WOULD WOULD
WOULD WOULD WOULD- I WOULD
APPRECIATE AYE AYE IT WOULD
RESONATE A BIT MORE BUT I THINK
IN THIS INSTANCE I DO
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT- THE
AUTHOR. HAS PROPOSED- APPLYING
THIS BILL TO THE TWO
INCORPORATED CITIES SAID- THAT
SHE'S LAID OUT IN THIS BILL SO
WITH THAT AGAIN. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TO MOVE THIS FOR TO
KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING.
OUT TO THE AUTHOR ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. YES AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE- AS
A WHOLE ALL OF US COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND I AND F. I WAS
GOING TO BE A RANKING
COMMITTEES OF IMPORTANCE I
WOULD SAY HOUSING IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I FEEL
LIKE THE WORK THAT WE- SEE
BEFORE US- THERE'S MANY WAYS TO
FIX THE PROBLEM BUT WE HAVE TO
GRAPPLE AS WE SAID IN THE
COMMITTEE HERE. WITH SERIOUS
SERIOUS ISSUES SO- YOU KNOW I'M
JUST GOING TO REALLY QUICKLY
TELL YOU KNOW YESTERDAY I HAD A
CALL FROM A CATHOLIC PRIEST IN
MY DISTRICT ABOUT THE RV'S.
MANY OF THEM PARKING AND FULLER
TEN BECAUSE OTHER CITIES ARE
NOT ALLOWING- SO DO WE ENFORCE
THEIR- PRODUCT CALL WITH THE
JUDGE DAVID CARTER WHO IS. NOW
BECOME. LEGENDARY FOR WORKING
ON HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND NOW IS ALL ABOUT IN.
LOS ANGELES- OUT ON SKID ROW.
AND SO WE AS LOCALS COUNCIL.
COUNTY PEOPLE STATE WE CONTINUE
TO MEET AND MEET AND TALK AND
TALK AND TRY TO PUT MONEY AT IT
AND YET. YOU KNOW SOMETHINGS
ARE WORKING SOMETHING'S ARM ARK
THIS BILL IS NARROWED TO TWO
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS. IN MY
OWN DISTRICT AND IT IS A
LIFELINE IT'S A LIFELINE TO
SAY. IF WE CAN DO SOMETHING NOW
TO POTENTIALLY KEEP EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE THEN IT'S A
STEP FORWARD. AND YET I 100%
AGREE WITH YOU PRODUCTION IS A
HUGE PROBLEM AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO GET SOLVED ANY TIME SOON.
AND I HOPE THAT THE GOVERNOR
LISTENS TO US THIS YEAR AND
SIGNS PRODUCTION BILLS BUT THAT
BEING SAID I ASKED FOR AN- AYE
VOTE FOR TO DAY FOR THIS BILL
AB NINE SEVENTY EIGHT. THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED SHE'LL. CHIU ICE AIRTEL
NO. SPARE TONER- GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING QUICK
SILVA HI QUICK SILVA EYEING
WICKS LOOKS AT. THE VOTES FIVE
TWO TO HEAR BILLS OUT LET'S GO
BACK TO THE ROLE FOR ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO NEED TO ADD ON FILE
ITEM ONE AB EIGHT SIX ONE
BENNETT. CAUGHT UP TO MEMBERS
APRIL APRIL I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE WICKS. WICKS BY.
SIX TWO TWO THE BILLS OUT AND
FILE ITEM TO EAT- WE JUST HAD
FALLEN TO FALLEN THREE AB TEN
SIXTY ONE. THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GABRIEL ZERO I. SEVEN SEVEN
LOADING ONE NOT VOTING AS I
SAID BEFORE THE BILL'S ALSO OUT
WITHOUT- OR JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE
STAFFER YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK IN
GETTING ALL THESE BILLS OUT OF
OUR POLICY COMMITTEE AND- WE
WILL AWAIT THE SECOND HALF OF
THIS YEAR WITH SENATE BILLS AND
WITH THAT. WE ARE NOW DROWNED.